Media downplay new revelations regarding
a sexual assault allegation against Joe
Biden reporters keep asking Trump pretty
dumb questions and politicians waver on
reopening and ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show the ben shapiro show is
sponsored by expressvpn surf the web
with peace of mind sign up now express
it VPN calm /ban okay so we've got some
good news we've got some bad news this
morning the bad news is that not much
has changed in terms of our knowledge
level about coronavirus that are still a
lot of vagueness as far as what we know
and what we do not know we do know that
the death rate from actual infection of
coronavirus are significantly lower than
originally proposed they are not 3%
they're not 4% they're well under 1% the
question is how far under because each
point one is a multiple of the flu so if
it's a point one that's the same as the
flu point two is double the flu point
three is triple the flu and so on in all
likelihood what we're looking at is
somewhere between point three and point
six which is at least three to six times
as deadly as the flu plus this thing
spreads three times as fast as the flu
which means that you're going to end up
with a multiple of deaths absent social
distancing and that is what the models
are beginning to show today is that as
people consider reopening there will be
additional deaths now people are using
this as an excuse to suggest that we
have to remain shut down forever but
this is the reality of life if we stay
locked up in our homes for any reason
rates of flu deaths will go down any
communicable disease will go down rates
of herpes will go to any disease that is
communicated by people being in close
contact with one another will go down
when you are at home on the other hand
things like heart disease or cancer
those are really not going to change
very much and you're not gonna be able
to at your treatment if you are at home
but the communicable diseases are always
gonna go down when you keep people at
home car accident deaths are going to go
down there are just certain things that
are gonna go down so recognizing that
disease continues to exist in our
society and that we're going to go out
of our houses that means that there will
be additional deaths the question is how
many additional deaths so there are new
models out today trying to describe how
many new deaths will be created by
people going out and this is hard to
model because we don't know the extent
to which people are actually going to
social distance now I have a lot of
faith in the American people I think
that most people are smart and
risk-averse enough to say 6 feet away
from each other to our masks in public
places I don't think that people are
going to be going out on mass
ac/dc concerts and & macking I just
don't think that's what's going to
happen here a very 90s language er but I
think that is is unlikely I think most
people are interested in social
distancing most people recognize that
the risk still remains according to the
CDC state-level forecasts very widely
reflecting differences in early epidemic
phases timing of interventions and model
specific assumptions
according to the CDC models the factor
in strong contact reduction suggest new
deaths will continue to occur but will
slow substantially over the next four
weeks
conversely models that do not
incorporate as strong contact reductions
suggest that total deaths may continue
to rise quickly which of course makes
perfect sense virus has not gone away
the only thing that's happened is that
we all went in our homes now where we
meet each other is also going to make a
big difference if we are outside and we
are somewhat far away from one another
that's gonna be a lot better than if we
all rush back to restaurants and
baseball games it's gonna be a while
until we are in close quarters with one
another I think that's gonna be largely
discouraged not only societally and
socially which is important but also by
government one model that's frequently
cited by the White House coronavirus
task force up this prediction that's
well again this would be the eye hme
model the one from University of
Washington that was subject to all of
this controversy because early on it
suggested 100 and 200 40,000 deaths and
then it downgraded that to about 60,000
deaths and it's been upgrading it again
because their assumptions were that we
were all gonna stay in our houses and
told you in first which was really not
going to happen now they've upgraded
again and suggested that there will be
74,000 Americans dead by August if
people go out and engage in some level
of social distancing again they aren't
that model is not based on them on them
inputting what they think the level of
social distancing will be it's based on
curve fitting from other countries that
are starting to to end their lockdowns
the projection was adjusted due to
longer peaks in some states and signs
that people are becoming more active
again so it is actually just curve
fitting to the data that is currently
known that model has become increasingly
accurate over time it was suggesting
that there are gonna be about 67,000
deaths before the lockdown started - and
now that the lock downs are starting to
end they're suggesting 74,000 deaths
over the course of the next few months
and let's be real about this okay let's
be absolutely real about this there is
no scenario in which people go back out
and start to socially distance and
engage in meaningful economic activity
or the death rates don't go up that is
just going to happen and everybody
understands that left right and center
and any pilot
or any member of the media who
fulminates over this is lying to you any
politician who suggests that they are
not willing to they're not willing to
take any measure that allows one more
death to take place it's just not true
okay everybody who's making public
policy is balancing a variety of
interests and one of the things that we
balance in public policy as I've been
saying since the very outset of this is
the additional risk to Americans
additional risk means additional death
end of story
so the question is in very blunt terms
is the increased death rate from what is
currently projected at sixty four
thousand to sixty to seventy four
thousand over the course of the next
three months is that worth reopening the
American economy and I think most
Americans would probably say yes frankly
speak and most Americans would probably
say yes Nate silver over at 538 makes
this point right he's saying that
anybody who's suggesting the death rate
goes to zero is just not telling you the
truth what we are currently discussing
is if there are three or four hundred
deaths a day nationwide from coke in
nineteen in a country or seventy five
hundred people a day typically die is
that enough to shut down the entire
American economy the answer obviously is
going to be no we got some more of this
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that right now is a it's
rough time and a lot of great companies
that are doing everything they can to
help us get through this trying time and
zip recruiter is now more important than
ever zip recruiters focus has not
changed they're still doing what they've
done from the beginning they're helping
people who need jobs find work and
they're helping growing businesses find
the right people for their open roles as
our habits change as the market begins
to reopen as we begin to see which
businesses have been most hard-hit and
which businesses are going to recover
fastest it's important to have a fluid
job market zip recorder makes that
happen zip Roker is dedicated to helping
you get hired whether you're looking for
jobs and caretaking delivering food and
goods building medical facilities
supplying protective equipment and so
much more and many more businesses are
gonna be reopening in the very near
future in states across America in fact
zip recruiters app it'll send you up to
date job openings so you can be one of
the first to apply which is a great
advantage to you if you're actively
hiring zip recruiter will invite
candidates to apply to your most urgent
roles making it faster and easier to
reach the people you need by connecting
people who need jobs and companies that
need people zip recruit is working with
all of us so we can keep moving forward
let's work together
zip recruiter comm slash work together
that zip recruiter comm slash work
together I'll say they're doing
something vital right now considering
the fluidity and the and the holdup in
the labor market zip recruited comm
work together go check them out right
now it's the governor Gavin Newsom in
California he continues to suggest that
his state is weeks away from changing
its stay-at-home order but people are
just not obeying this and the fact is
that people are going out to beaches
Gavin Newsom was fulminating over this
last night he was suggesting that he is
basically going to keep America locked
down ad infinitum because people are
going out he suggested that he's going
to keep this going specifically because
people are going out meanwhile as of
Tuesday morning over a million people in
the United States have been infected
more than 56,000 have already died
Governor Brian Kemp says Georgia is
moving forward with data and information
and decisions from the local public
health officials and working within the
guidelines of the great plan the
president has laid out hard-hit cities
aren't starting to test asymptomatic
people LA County is going to expand
coronavirus testing Tuesday to include
delivery drivers rideshare drivers taxi
drivers even if they feel fine according
to LA mayor Eric Garcetti and that makes
perfect sense you want to see if people
who are out there driving an
asymptomatic people who are in close
contact with the stuff that you're
touching and in close contact in a car
with you driving you around that those
people don't actually have kovat 19 and
aren't spreading it to people who are in
the back of their cars gar said he said
these are folks that are on the front
lines helping us get to where we need to
go helping us save to have food
delivered to our homes same thing is
happening in Boston where mayor Martin
Walsh said that 1,000 a symptomatic
residents will undergo diagnostic and
antibody testing by Friday to evaluate
exposure to the virus in the city also
starting on Tuesday Georgia public
health workers will start visiting
randomly selected homes in two of
Georgia's largest counties to conduct
antibody testing through blood samples
and that program is voluntary now
whether or not the antibodies actually
mean that you're immune to the vaccine
that is still up in the air we don't
actually know that you can just go out
willy-nilly and you're fine forever like
that is not clear at this point but the
antibody test will tell us how deadly
the disease is and they'll also tell us
if a hotspot starts to starts to rise up
now the question is how far the testing
has to go because right now this is sort
of become the the buzzword for people
who want the lockdowns to continue is it
just keeps shouting testing testing
testing and the question is what does
the testing actually accomplish so as
I've said before all testing can really
do at this point is help you locate a
hot spot and then presumably you can
contact race in that hot spot but people
would say well
South Korea did it did it successfully
South Korea has a grand total of eleven
thousand diagnosed cases in South Korea
the United States has over a million
okay so this thing is spreading faster
in the United States we did I already
spent spread far more quickly unless you
are willing to allow the virus to
basically burn down to zero again and
then we restart with contact tracing and
testing which by the way it would take a
hell of a long time and you keep the
economy shut down for months more what
South Korea did in the first place was
great but we're not gonna get that
restart it's just not gonna happen
unless this thing burns all the way out
during the summer and then hopefully we
have capacity in September there's a
reason other European countries are not
doing what South Korea did it is just
not possible for the United States to do
what South Korea did absent a complete
burnout so I've I said from the
beginning we had to move from a Chinese
lockdown model to a South Korean test
and trace model is becoming clearer
thanks to the asymptomatic nature of
this disease that's an incredibly
difficult you might be able to do that
in certain specific areas but even in
areas where you have hotspots your first
notification of the hot spot is unlikely
to be asymptomatic testing your first
notification of the hot spot is likely
to be hospitals getting overwhelmed with
people who are walking in with actual
symptoms now that doesn't mean that we
can't ramp up testing or that we
shouldn't ramp up testing we can and we
should but we cannot sit home this is
the the timeline is just too immediate
on this thing so when you see LA mayor
Eric Garcetti saying maybe we can scale
back measures in a few weeks with baby
steps let me just tell you I live in LA
people ain't waiting they're not they're
not gonna wait until June or July for
Eric Garcetti to give them the go-ahead
the traffic on Ventura Boulevard today
is an actual serious traffic either
there been actual traffic jams on the
time people are not going to sit home
and wait to go bankrupt because Eric
Garcetti says that your risk has risen
if you are a young person under the age
of 40 by point zero zero one or whatever
the actual stat is the actual staff for
people who are who are under the age of
forty and healthy is really close to
zero those people are not going to
continue to sit home because Eric
Garcetti says you're supposed to stay
home there's Eric Garcetti yesterday
suggest maybe we can scale back measures
in a few weeks
my sense is probably in the next 2 to 6
weeks we'll see some baby steps forward
you know it's so critical to have a few
things in place it's not really about a
date or how few cases you have it's
about the infrastructure you have to
handle opening up so the good news is
the bad
here the good news is and thank you to
everybody listening what we've been
doing has worked it has saved thousands
of lives but the bad news is that means
according to the USC prevalence study we
have about 96% of us that could still
get this and if we open up the wrong way
we could have by August 1st 95% of us
with kovat 19 okay first of all that's
not true if we open this up it would not
be 95 percent of us have covered 19 by
August first and this thing was in
California by January the idea that over
the next two months that everyone in
California was gonna get a cup at 19 and
that Americans are smarter than that
Californians god help us even
Californians are smarter than that
and let's be real there are
countervailing problems here there's a
new survey showing that one in four
Americans say that they're losing their
will to comply according to a survey
conducted by Celts and global one in
four Americans say they've already
reached their breaking point a hundred
percent said it would definitely reach
that point if they're forced to stay
home through mid June a hundred percent
in all 1900 US citizens over the age of
18 were surveyed earlier this month 72%
said they expected to reach a breaking
point by mid June if stay at home orders
aren't lifted 100 percent of respondents
said they would snap if all this last
longer than six months the survey was
conducted between April 3rd and April
6th that time 16 percent said they had
already hit their breaking point and as
the money stops flowing as people lose
their jobs permanently and they're going
to food banks and they're on
unemployment insurance those numbers are
going to skyrocket a lot of people have
not felt the actual economic fallout of
this thing quite yet because of the
government hiding people over young
Americans are the people most likely to
say they've reached the breaking point
of course because young Americans are
more active than older Americans also
young Americans typically do not have
houses so they don't have backyards that
they can go out into also young
Americans are not at high risk from this
thing if you're under the age of 30
ain't dying from it unless you have this
serious pre-existing condition if you're
under 40 you're not dying of it unless
you have a serious pre-existing
condition this does have implications
for whether the lockdowns are even going
to be possible to continue so we're
gonna get to more of this in just one
second like what would be the most
responsible way to do this also some
actual very good news out of Oxford
we'll get to that in just one moment
first the second amendment is very
relevant these days the Supreme Court
refused yesterday to step in and stop
New York State laws that really infringe
on the Second Amendment and that means
that you really have to be protective of
your own
ability to keep and bear arms right now
before States start cracking down on
this sort of stuff more also as we see
the government jumping into American
life in heretofore unforeseen ways
imagine the fact that right now a
Republican is president and that
Republican has no interest in seeing the
government maximize its authority and
power in the midst of a pandemic that is
simply not the case with so many places
around the country which are forcibly
shutting down gun shops for example
trying to do that as quote-unquote
non-essential businesses in the middle
of a pandemic while releasing tons of
people from jail you know who agrees
with me are the folks over at Bravo
Company Bravo Company was started in the
garage of a veteran of the US Marine
Corps in Hartland Wisconsin the people
at Bravo company manufacturing support
the right of responsible private
individuals have the access and ability
to employ the same tools at civilian law
enforcement as a means of defending
ourselves our loved ones our communities
and our freedoms should a threatening
situation ever arise BCM assumes that
when a rifle leaves their shop it will
be used in a life-or-death situation by
a responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas quality is
of top value to them every component of
a BCM rifle is assembled hand assembled
and tested to learn more about bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
Bravo Company MFG comm you can discover
more about their products special offers
and upcoming news that's Bravo Company
MFG comm if you need more convincing
find out even more about BCM in the
awesome people who make their products
at youtube.com slash bravo company USA
awesome folks amazing products Bravo
Company MFG calm or youtube.com / Bravo
Company USA ok so here's a bit of good
news speaking of the tests the tests are
ramping up we're seeing a couple of ways
in which the tests are ramping up the
white house was was promoting yesterday
this this new plan to ramp up testing
they they released a white house
blueprints that blueprint is sort of
vague as to what exactly they hope will
be the level of testing that is
available as states reopen they suggest
that states local tribal governments
have to develop testing plans and rapid
response programs and maximize the use
of all available testing platforms they
said today they are working with private
groups across the nation to ramp up
testing and that is in fact happening
you're starting to see major chain
stores developing the possibility for
points of contact test which is really
really good
president Trump met with the heads of
major retailers yesterday pharmacy
change testing labs including Walmart
and CVS health and the White House
released what I call the blueprints of
its testing plans President Trump said
and
garden press-conference we're deploying
the full power and strength of the
federal government's help state cities
and help local governments get this
horrible plague over with Admiral Brett
you are the administration official
overseeing coronavirus testing efforts
said the federal government would be
able to supply every state with supplies
and tests they need to dramatically
increase the number of tests really what
they mean is they're going to be able to
increase the number of tests such that
each state will have enough tests for 2%
of the population meanwhile quest
Diagnostics has announced that they are
going to begin selling Cova 19 antibody
tests now we still don't know whether
the antibody actually protects or
provides it serious immunity but quest
diagnostics is offering a new antibody
test for 119 bucks or potentially less
if you have insurance quest says this
test checks for a type of antibody
called
immunoglobulin G that is the result of
past or recent exposure to Cova 19 also
known as corona virus the human body
produces antibodies as part of the
immune response to the virus
it usually takes 10 to 18 days to
produce enough antibodies to be detected
in the blood so the test can help
determine if you have been previously
exposed it can check whether your body
has produced enough antibodies whether
or not you were exposed jaye wilmuth who
is the senior vice president and chief
medical officer for quest says with the
introduction of this test and service
Quest is making it easy for people to
access quality testing for antibodies to
the virus which caused kovat 19 so all
of this is useful all this is good none
of it is going to prevent people from
going out and working so here's the good
news here's a here's an actual piece of
good news there's an Oxford group that
says that they may in fact be able to
produce millions of doses of vaccine
they're testing a vaccine right now they
may be able to produce millions of doses
of vaccine they're hoping by September
which would be unbelievable or that
would be a triumph of the human spirit
and of the human ingenuity if we are
able to produce a human a human
available vaccine by September we were
told 12 to 18 months that would mean
that was actually six months which is
just insanely fast according to the New
York Times in the worldwide race for a
vaccine to stop coronavirus the
laboratory sprinting fastest is at
oxford most other teams have had to
start with small clinical trials of a
few hundred participants to demonstrate
safety scientists at the university's
Jenner Institute had a head start on a
vaccine having have improved in previous
trials that similar inoculations
including one last year against an
earlier corona virus were harmless to
humans this has enabled them to leap
ahead and schedule tests of their new
coronavirus vaccine involving more than
six thousand
by the end of next month hoping to show
not only that it is safe but also that
it works which would be what again that
would be miraculous
that'd be miraculous and by the way if
there's a vaccine and that thing is
available I like the end of May what you
are talking about would be the fastest
recovery in the history of human
economics right if a vaccine were
available and the vaccine were made
available broadly to the American people
by the end of the summer people would
start investing again the money would
come back online all the jobs would come
back people would be ready to spend
we've all been locked down for over a
month some of us for more than that many
of us aren't gonna be likely locked down
for several more weeks
the Oxford scientists now say that with
an emergency approval from regulators
the first few million doses of their
vaccine could be available by September
at least several months ahead of any
other announced efforts if it proves to
be effective and now they have promising
news suggesting it might so this is like
the best news that we have heard in
weeks and weeks and weeks right I've
said before if there's a deus ex machina
that changes everything
obviously this would be that accepted to
be it it would be a science ex machina
right scientists at the National
Institute of Health's rocky mountain
laboratory in Montana
last month inoculated six rhesus macaque
monkeys with sick with single doses of
the oxford vaccine the animals were then
exposed to heavy quantities of the virus
causing the pandemic exposure that had
consistently sickened other monkey's in
the lab more than 28 days later all six
were healthy said Vincent Munster the
researcher conducting the test he said
the rhesus macaque is pretty much the
closest thing we have to humans
he said he expected to share it with
other scientists this week this is his
paper and submitted to a peer-reviewed
journal now immunity and monkeys is not
a guarantee a vaccine would provide the
same degree of protection for humans a
Chinese company that recently started a
clinical trial with 144 participants has
also said it's vaccine was effective in
rhesus macaques but with dozens of
efforts now underway to find a vaccine
the monkey results are the latest
indicator that Oxford's accelerated
venture is emerging as a bellwether
while the bellwether it's a very very
fast clinical programs at Amelia and
Meany
director of the vaccine program at the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation which
is providing financial support to many
competing efforts by the way I've seen
some conspiracy crazy conspiracy
theorists were angry at Bill and Melinda
Gates because they back vaccines shut
the F up like seriously what's wrong
with you people what's wrong with you
people who got thousands of people dying
every day around the world including
thousands in the United States and
you're pissed off at the people who are
spending millions of their own dollars
to develop a vaccine find a hobby go
learn to knit or something my god
which potential vaccine will emerge from
the Scramble its most successful is
impossible to know until clinical trial
data becomes available more than one
vaccine might be needed in any case some
may work more effectively in others than
others and groups like children or older
people having more than one variety
would be a good thing but the oxford
trial will provide lessons about the
nature of the corona virus so we'll find
out this would be and so it's hard not
to get your hopes up when you read news
like that but you know what it's okay
get your hopes up just don't do anything
irresponsible I get your hopes up and
then we'll move on to the next hope if
that doesn't that doesn't work right
hydroxychloroquine didn't work that was
a hope didn't work there's this drug
from Gilead Sciences we're still waiting
maybe that won't work it's okay to get
your hopes up it just doesn't okay to be
responsible obviously in the meantime
how exactly are we gonna go about
reopening well the good news is again
I'm very comforted there are a lot of
people who are very upset the President
Trump is president at a time like this
one of the reasons I am comforted the
President Trump is president is not
because of the crazy stuff he says
during press conferences frankly that's
Trump and you know he's gonna do it and
stop it like really does the Sun rise in
the morning is the sky blue does
president some say President Trump say
crazy crap at press conferences hey
these are all things that are just
natural facts of life but what is not a
natural fact of life is the fact that
the federal government is not using this
pandemic in order to seize ultimate
power that is a good thing that is a
very good thing that is why it is a good
thing that the Attorney General William
bar put out a letter today telling
people that they need to actually take
into account the Constitution as they as
they pursue these lockdown strategies he
says as the Department of Justice
explained recently in guidance to states
and localities taking steps to battle
the pandemic even in times of emergency
when reasonable and temporary
restrictions are placed on rights the
First Amendment and federal statutory
law prohibit discrimination against
religious institutions and religious
believers the legal restrictions on
state and local authority are not
limited to discrimination against
religious institutions and religious
believers the Constitution also forbids
discrimination against disfavored speech
and unto interference with the national
economy if a state or local ordinance
crosses the line from an appropriate
exercise of authority to stop the spread
of Kovan 19 into an overbearing
infringement of constitutional and
statutory protections the DOJ may have
an obligation to address that overreach
in federal court that's a very good
thing it's a very good thing that people
are are concerned
about that sort of overage okay in just
a second we're gonna talk about whether
people are being responsible because
answer is mostly they are mostly they
are and then we're gonna talk about
overreach in the media which continues
to undercut their credibility when they
talk about issues like Kovan 19 it turns
out that credibility is a thing that
once it is lost cannot be regained very
easily so if you lose credibility
because you are a political hack and
then you spend all of your time talking
about Cove in nineteen people are going
to take it as though you're a political
hack talking about Cove in nineteen at
least if you purport to be objective
right those of us who acknowledge we're
not objective at least we're honest
about our own biases this is one of the
problems for the media they rarely do
this okay so in a second we'll get to
more of that but first I want to talk to
you about a fantastic new podcast now
right now business risk takers they're
the ones who are going to be helping the
economy recover and if you're interested
in business and risk-taking and making
good decisions in business and also how
dramatic all this stuff can be you
really should check out the brand new
weekly podcast from wonder it's called
business Wars each season digs deep into
some of the greatest corporate rivalries
of all time think Facebook versus
snapchat or Nike versus Adidas on each
episode we give you an inside look at
what inspired entrepreneurs to take
risks that drove their companies to new
heights or into the ground alternatively
go check it out right now go check out
wonder e's new podcasts business wars
make sure to subscribe to business Wars
or other great podcasts from wandering
on Apple podcasts Spotify or wherever
you're listening right now as you say
states are moving to ease these lock
downs they should be moving to ease
these lock downs and the only question
is what are the strategies there ought
to be used when you see people
formulating from their perches in New
York their secure perches in the media
right they get to do what I do I said
this yesterday they have the we're
privileged we are privileged we get to
sit in our houses and have a job and
continue to work many people do not when
they sit in their houses and they
fulminate against people working it
really is kind of gross and thus it is
pretty amazing to watch more and more
people on the Left doing this sort of
stuff the fact is that there are a
couple different strategies that have to
take place while we wait for the testing
regime to ramp up to the point where
presumably we are not just identifying
hotspots but also being able to identify
people like right at the moment of
contact well that all Graham stop people
are going to have to get back to work
because the center cannot hold this is
just not going to work there is a study
out of Israel suggesting that perhaps
the best strategy here is not testing
and
contact tracing in a country of 330
million people with incredible
population density and with a million
already diagnosed cases perhaps the best
strategies to focus on the vulnerable
there's a paper from Nam Joshua and she
shall have Schwartz they're both
professors at Hebrew University in
Jerusalem and they say that the idea
would be to identify the vulnerable age
cut-offs and comorbidities have them
observe strict social distancing for
their own protection while receiving
assistance from the state the weakness
of the approach is whether it is all it
is at all practical to observe a
differential social distancing regime
and whether the total strict social
distancing is too much to bear over an
extended period of time but here's the
reality either we're all gonna do it or
some of us are going to do it better
some of us than all of us particularly
those who are most vulnerable and by the
way this is something that we do with
vulnerable populations on a regular
basis if you're immunocompromised then
we make provisions for you regularly if
your kin immunocompromised
we don't suggest that your life is gonna
look just like people who are not immuno
compromised anybody who's
immunocompromised will tell you all the
precautions that they take on a daily
basis in order to protect themselves so
tranching people by population and
recognizing the risk factors by
population that would be the key that's
why you need the antibody tests so you
can figure out exactly who is most
vulnerable it's why you need broader
testing and you need better reporting of
medical conditions underlying this thing
so people can get back to work all of
this is important and meanwhile I think
you can trust the American people to be
smart and how they reappropriation post
that are going to be that are going to
be rolled out in very short order which
obviously is good news but also the
American people as I mentioned yesterday
they are generally being responsible
according to the Associated Press with
staff wearing masks checking customers
temperatures using disposable paper
place mats
some of the nation's restaurants reopen
for dine and service on Monday as States
loosened more coronavirus restrictions
many eateries remain closed amid safety
concerns and community backlash
restaurants in Georgia Tennessee
Anchorage Alaska welcomed diners back
albeit for a different dining experience
than before in Louisiana
the governor said restaurants will be
allowed to seat people outside starting
on Friday which by the way would be a
good idea right seating people outside
is a good thing you just if I had a
restaurant I would be looking to set up
tables in the parking lot seriously
because that the open air is a much
better environment than a closed
restaurant
- who manages 87 waffle house
restaurants he says were ecstatic to
have them back a lot of people I think
want to get back to the new normal which
will be social distancing and all that
but they'll be able to eat inside the
restaurant the new normal includes
employees wearing masks booths clothes
to keep customers apart and traditional
plastic placemat menus replaced by paper
menus they are discardable so people are
not touching the same surfaces over and
over there are 39 different requirements
in the state of Georgia the restaurants
have to follow including observing a
limit of 10 customers per 500 square
feet and ensuring that all employees
wear face coverings hey all of this is
good
all of this is responsible all of it is
okay meanwhile there are still people
who seem wedded to the idea of the
lockdowns for a variety of political
reasons on the one hand you have people
who are wedded to the lockdowns because
they wants to see the government
spending increase and on the other hand
you see people who want the lockdowns
because they actually think that it's a
leverage point for workers against
employers which is perfectly insane in a
world where employers are going under by
the bushel Rasheeda Talib who is one of
the members of the squad just terrible
the congresswoman from Michigan who and
she's not spouting idiotic antisymmetric
propaganda he's saying really dumb
things about the economy she suggests
that workers are supposed to push back
against reopening really they don't have
jobs they're not workers right now there
are unemployed people they're gonna push
back against reopening Rasheeda Talib
has it easy she's got a job paid for by
the taxpayer a lot of people they don't
have jobs and employers are going under
and she's suggesting that now's a great
time for a work strike genius stuff here
from Rasheeda Talib if you are afraid to
go to work do not go to work and I know
this is hard but you have no right you
have every right to make sure your life
is put first and to fight back I don't
care if it's labor organizing this late
in the game or if it's demanding that
your life is not treated as if it's
disposable but I want you not to be
afraid to go to work I want you to
organize with your other co-workers and
demand better demand that your life
again is put first and that your help is
part first so I would push back no
matter what these decisions and these
other folks and these task force that
are being put together your gut feeling
follow that good luck it means here's
the good luck if you are young and you
are healthy and your business reopens
and you don't have any serious risk and
you're out living with an older person
and your
and your business and these block downs
are lifted and your place of business
says listen your job is not something
you can do from home right you're
working manufacturing you have to be at
the factory you're like you know what I
just don't I'm a little nervous today
there are now 30 million people out of
work and many of them will fill that job
yeah it doesn't mean that employers
shouldn't keep things safe employers
have the most interest in keeping things
safe look at Tyson Foods which is
shutting down factories because of
coronavirus I don't know what the hell
she's talking about
the Rasheeda Talib types or the or the
paul krugman types Paul Krugman has an
idiotic column today suggesting that
people should stop worrying about the
deficit at a time when we were blowing
out seven trillion dollars in spending
he says the only fiscal thing to fear is
deficit fear itself deficits don't
matter anymore I'm old enough to
remember when Paul Krugman thought that
modern monetary theory was a bunch of
claptrap modern monetary theory is the
idea we can just spend endlessly because
people will just continue buying our
bonds because the American economy is
still powerful now he is he's out there
basically embracing modern monetary
theory he suggests that deficit vultures
are hypocrites and then we shouldn't be
worried about the effects of Cova 1900
for some i popping numbers last week the
CBO released preliminary economic and
budget projections for the next two
years which were both shocking and
unsurprising soaring unemployment will
cause federal revenues to plunge and
lead to a surge in spending on safety
net programs like unemployment insurance
Medicaid and food stamps and in the
large relief packages Congress has
passed and the Budget Office projects a
deficit that will temporarily rise to
levels we haven't seen since World War
two it expects federal debt to rise to
108 percent from 79% of GDP which sounds
scary but the government will be able to
borrow that money at incredibly low
interest rates in fact real interest
rates rates on government bonds
protected against inflation are negative
right now so the burden of the
additional debt as measured by the rise
in federal interest payments will be
negligible so don't worry about it guys
we'll always be able to pay it back we
won't have to inflate our way out mm-hmm
sure Paul sure as appetite for American
debt wanes because we have the
government intervening in our economy
and deepening a depression I'm sure that
people will continue to buy that debt
I'm sure it'll be totally fine no
problem whatsoever okay in just a second
we're gonna get to the media in all of
this because you know we try here on the
show to bring you as much listen you
know my political viewpoint you do but
I'm trying to be as objective as I can
about the data this is not from from any
members of the media who have undercut
their own credibility and then they're
surprised when people don't believe in
in nineteen after they destroyed their
own credibility on a variety of other
issues we're gonna get to that in just
one second it's really dangerous this is
a time when you actually need to be able
to trust people who theoretically know
what they are talking about or at least
conveying information from people who
know what they are talking about and yet
Trust in media are at an all-time low
and that makes perfect sense we'll
explain why in just one second first let
us talk about the fact that it's easy at
times like this to turn into a beach bum
right here you're sitting at home
letting that beer grow out getting all
fat never taken off the never taking off
the sweat pants and you haven't brushed
her teeth in years you're starting to
look like a meth addict those teeth are
falling out well perhaps you should
start with the teeth this is what clip
comes in 75% of us use old worn-out
bristles that are ineffective even more
people forget to floss it daily good
health starts with good habits quit
makes it easy by delivering all the oral
care essentials you need to brush and
floss better the quip electric
toothbrush has time sonic vibrations
with 30 second pulses to guide a dentist
recommended 2 minute routine there's
even a size down version designed for
kids
paired with quips anti cavity toothpaste
in mint or watermelon you get all the
ingredients teeth actually need and none
they don't quit has an eco-friendly
refillable floss with a dispensary to
keep for life expanding string that
helps to clean in between but brush had
toothpaste floss refills they are
automatically delivered on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five bucks each you don't want
to go to the CVS you don't have to now
you can get all of this stuff delivered
directly to your door it's a friendly
reminder when it's time for a refresh
and to stay committed to your oral
health shipping is free and once you
develop the habit then it'll just
continue and the great news is again you
never have to think about it again it
just arrives at your door if you go to
get quick calm slash to Pierrot right
now get your first refill free that is
your first refill free at get quick calm
slash appear oh that is GE t qu IP comm
slash Shapiro get quick comm slash
apparel quit the good habits company go
check them out right now okay in just a
second when you gets you the lack of
credibility in the media which is a
serious problem for the United States
trying to find sources of information
that are good we'll get to that in just
one second first being locked in right
now that means that you might be crying
salty tears but you can refill all the
salty tears you need right here with two
count them two one two check out that
math to left is tears tumble you get all
that one you subscribe right now when
you become a daily where insider plus or
all-access member you get a second
leftist years tumblr I am not joking I
am not kidding
daily wire members get many amazing
benefits including of course the
Magnificent incomparable
simple singular leftist ears tumblr you
also get an ad-free website experience
access to all of our live broadcast and
show library the full three hours of the
Ben Shapiro show access to the mailbag
and now exclusive election inside op-eds
from moi daily wire members also get to
ask us questions during backstage you
also get to participate in all access
live that is our brand-new interactive
programming featuring one of us daily
Waterhouse's we hang out with you each
night at 8:00 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific I believe I'm hanging out with
you tonight and you'd ask me all the
questions it's t-shirt time that's what
we always do during all access live this
is content for our all-access members
that has been temporarily open up to all
membership levels to bring us together
while we are stuck being apart if you
haven't already go download the daily
wire apps you can get all of our great
content on the go again
become an Insider plus or all-access
member and double your tears with two
leftist tears tumblers head on over to
daily wire.com slash subscribe to get
started and get 10% off with the coupon
code Shapiro that is daily wire.com
slash subscribe coupon code Shapiro get
the rarest of all beverage vessels times
two you're listening to the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so President Trump continues to be in
this ongoing war with the media and I'm
not sure that it's in his best interest
but I'm absolutely positive that the
media largely deserve it the media have
been focused on virtually all the wrong
issues here they do not bring you any
sort of well calibrated information
instead it seems to be largely hysterics
if you read to paragraph 19 in a New
York Times article you get to the hard
data very often but if you just watch
cable news all you get is a bunch of
screaming Talking Heads telling you that
either it's the end of the world on the
one hand or not to worry about it it's
the flu on the other all of this is
ridiculous
it's ridiculous you know well calibrated
public policy would be the way to go
about all of this
recognizing the risks being transparent
with the American people that's not what
you get from the media particularly the
media covering the White House media
covering the White House we should stop
honestly we should stop all televised
press briefings we should they're a
waste of time they're a complete waste
of time because or if you're gonna hold
these televised press briefings in a
time of pandemic the president shouldn't
show up it should be Burks it should be
foul she it should be the people who
know what they're talking about red
field and it shouldn't be the political
reporters on the White House beat it
should be the health reporters on the
White House beat it should be the people
over at the Washington Post who run
health 202 it shouldn't be the political
reporters who are busy writing democracy
dies in darkness Trump is a bad mean man
articles it should be the health
reporters over at the New York Times it
should be the people over at Politico
will actually write health policy on the
right it should be a vaq row over at
free op there should be people who
actually pay attention to health policy
right now asking specific questions that
can be information to the American
people that's not what we get however
instead we get Jim Acosta posturing for
the purposes of loving Jim Acosta
because Jim Acosta loves him like nobody
loves anybody Jim Acosta ladies find you
a man who loves you like Jim Acosta
loves Jim Acosta but Jim Acosta
apparently has a new friend in this
regard one of this friend is Olivia
nosey I'm not sure how her last name is
pronounced she is a New York magazine
correspondent yesterday she's at the
White House and she asked this question
to President Trump which is insanely
useless and obviously directed at just
getting Trump to blow up so then the
media can have a headline about how
Trump blows up which is completely not
only useless but counterproductive at
this point in time when you know people
are still out there dying and we're
trying to figure out the best way to
reopen the economy nothing I like better
than a bunch of posturing crap from the
media
more Americans over the course of six
weeks and died in the entirety of the
Vietnam War does he deserve to be
reelected
so yeah we've lost a lot of people but
if you look at what original projections
were 2.2 million
we're probably heading to 60,000 70,000
far too many one person who's too many
for this yeah its Trump handling that
question better than frankly I would
handle that question what a despicable
question first of all the Vietnam War
was a war that we've got into by choice
politically second of all the federal
government was lying throughout the
Vietnam War about what exactly was going
on thirdly the media were lying about
what was going on during the Vietnam War
fourthly a war is not like a pandemic
war is not contagious the notion that
the president is in is responsible for
anything other than the decisions that
the president makes during the pandemic
is insane if this many people die from
him so let's be real about this if
coronavirus were what one-third is
deadly would anybody be talking right
now about do you deserve to be President
because people are dying of the flu it's
more deadly and so it has greater
consequences but does that mean that
Trump is the one who is upping the death
count how about Andrew Cuomo does he
deserve to be governor in a state that's
lost 15,000 people bill de blasio does
he deserve to be mayor in a city that's
lost 12,000 people and what the hell is
that question what a stupid asinine
ridiculous question ari fleischer by the
way called out Olivia knows he about the
question cuz it's a ridiculous posturing
question that is designed to get her on
TV and it did and she immediately
responded shut the F up which is just
great journalism a massive massive
journalism a you wonder why the American
people don't trust your takes on this
stuff guys wonder why they are relegated
to looking at YouTube for videos of
doctors who they think are gonna confirm
what they already thought this is why
because you're not focused on bringing
their american people the truth
you're focused on a gotcha game with
trump meanwhile protecting joe biden I
mean the warm relationship between the
Democratic Party in the media has never
been in in more fine fettle than it is
right now listen to Nancy Pelosi and
Stephanie ruhle basically giving each
other a mutual massage on MSNBC
yesterday thank you thank you so much
thank you for this additional three
hundred and twenty billion dollars
American business needs it I appreciate
all that everyone in our government is
doing right now to help us in this
trying time thanks for your time this
morning well thank you for your
objective view of it all because that's
all very helpful it's all very helpful
thank you so much
this important issue thank you just
unbelievable but just you know by our
dinner or something I mean this is
really it's it's just it's insane so the
media continue to just be awful at their
jobs
speaking of awful at their jobs this is
all reinforced by the fact that they are
political hacks like insane political
hacks so this becomes most obvious when
you look at the media coverage of Joe
Biden's accuser so there's now more
active that there's no more evidence
against Joe Biden he sexually assaulted
a woman and then there ever was against
Brett Kavanaugh like a lot more evidence
okay Tara Reid is a woman who came
forward to suggest that Joe Biden
basically when she was when she was a
staffer in his office got her into a
lonely hallway and then proceeded to
sexually assault her picking up her
skirt and then penetrating her with his
fingers I mean like really bad stuff now
it turns out that not only was there
tape of her mother calling in to Larry
King and asking questions about how
staffers are supposed to report bad
things but also some of her neighbors to
separate neighbors have come forward to
say that the woman had told them about
the incident shortly after it occurred
one is her brother Colin Moulton and
also a friend who asked to remain
anonymous for pure fear of retribution
and now two more sources have come
forward to corroborate certain details
about Reid's claims one of them
according to Business Insider a former
neighbor of Reid's has told The Insider
for the first time on the record that
Reid disclosed details about the alleged
assault to her in the mid-1990s the
woman's name is Linda Lacasse she lives
next door to read in the mid 90s she
said this happened I know it did because
I remember talking about it the other
source is a woman named Lorraine Sanchez
who worked with Reid in the office of a
California State Senator in the mid 90s
and she told insiders she recalls Reid
complaining at the time that her former
boss in Washington DC had sexually
harassed her and that she had been fired
after raising concerns now listen none
of this means that Biden is necessarily
guilty maybe it didn't go like the woman
said it went maybe the woman
misperceived somehow although it's
difficult to imagine how you miss
perceived being sexually assaulted right
but maybe there's some disconnect okay
perhaps that is true I mean there's no
evidence other than what this woman had
to say and the fact that she had
contemporaneous accounts of it to people
does not mean it went down the way that
she thinks that it went down right I
mean this is what innocent until proven
guilty means and I hold that standard
for Brett Kavanaugh and I hold that
standard for Joe Biden too but Joe Biden
doesn't hold that standard for Brett
Kavanaugh so Joe Biden doesn't get to
hold that standard for Joe Biden either
but what's incredible is the media
differential the media cover
of this stuff so much insane journalism
like incredible levels of journalism
here's the Washington Post headline
yesterday about this covering this for
basically the first time the Washington
Post headline on Twitter read quote
developments in allegations against
Biden amplify efforts to question his
behavior is that even English is that
even English I mean shouldn't the actual
headline be two more women come forward
and confirm that Biden's sexual assault
accuser told them about sexual assault
in mid 90s like isn't that the headline
you know a headline in English what does
that even mean developments and
allegations against Biden amplify
efforts to question his behavior what
are the allegations what were they about
what was the topic whose amplified like
what that's that's Swahili you're not
even speaking English at this point what
the media will do in order to protect
Democrats he's insane insane
developments and allegations against
Biden so I assume they mean by that two
additional people saying that this woman
told them about it
amplify efforts to question his behavior
meaning that people are now going to
question his behavior so notice that is
the Andrew Clavin rule and it's exactly
correct when a Republican does something
bad the story is the Republican does
something bad when a Democrat does
something bad the story is that
Republicans are attacking Democrats for
doing something bad and that is the end
that's the actual headline right the the
headline that was put out by The
Washington Post changed I assume after I
tweeted about it because the actual
headline originally was just a
Republicans pounds headline now I have
to go look for it because I voting the
link from last night and actually
changed the headline ok the headline now
is Trump allies highlight new claims
regarding allegations against Biden ah
the Trump allies I'm sorry they didn't
change it Trump allies highlighting new
claims regarding allegations against
Biden that's the key here
is that Trump allies are focusing on
this again what is news II about the
fact that Republicans are reporting on
bad things Democrats did that's like
arguing that after after Mark Foley the
Republican Congress person was was
nailing pages in the in the mail pages
in the house back in 2006 the story is
Democrats focus on Mark Foley
accusations that's the headline not
congresswoman nailing mail pages
in the House of Representatives it's
just incredible it's incredible and by
the way the media coverage differential
took them like a month to even report on
the accusation you think they would have
waited a month so important on any
accusation about any Republican of
course not meanwhile you've got Joe's VP
candidates running around trying to
garner attention three females by the
way Carla Harris and Amy Klobuchar are
three for an Elizabeth Warren and Stacey
Abrams write all four females going or
and Gretchen Whitmer so five different
females going around doing press to try
and attract Joe Biden's attention
I mean Stacey Abrams is so desperate at
this point that she basically broke into
Biden's kitchen and boiled a rabbit I'm
not gonna be ignored Joe but not one of
them has been asked about the Tara Reid
allegations and particularly Camilla
Harris who was the leader in the Brett
Kavanaugh as a serial rapist routine
she's not been asked a single question
about this so here she was yesterday
Camilla harrassing Joe always talks
plain love me some Joe Biden five
seconds ago she was saying that she
believes Joe Biden's accusers here is
Camilla Harris he is saying that there
should be an equitable allocation of
recovery funds what does that mean
that's a fancy way for saying what Joe
always stops playing talk he speaks
straight and what are these things that
I want to make sure every community gets
enough so that they end up being equal
so that's a real different point that
equal share he's talking about equitable
meaning at the result will be everyone
ends up being equal okay and here is
tunnel Harris like a few months ago
talking about Joe Biden's accusers who
say that he was sniffing their hair and
massaging them and I respect them being
able to tell their story and having the
courage to do it
oh he's gonna have to make that decision
for himself I wouldn't tell what to do
it doesn't believable it's just amazing
like and now she's flipped in Oh Joe
always talks plain he's a really good
guy that the media when they are not
busy blaming Trump for vietnam-era of
level numbers on a pandemic which again
not comparable not comparable a war is
not like a pandemic when they're not
busy doing that routine you know and
just trying to play this tete-a-tete
game with Trump where where they where
they just yell at each other and then
both of them make headlines when they're
not busy doing that they're busy trying
to cover for Joe Biden and pretend that
none of this ever happened but don't
worry guys journalism is going to
continue as well the self congratulatory
nature of the journalists are just it's
just it's so off-putting just a few days
ago the New York Times put out an
opinion piece that suggested was a
column by jigna Belafonte profiling a
coronavirus victim named Joe Joyce
it included a passage in which Joyce's
daughter suggested her dad went on
cruise after seeing on Hannity and Fox
News the outbreak was under control Sean
Hannity covered this because Hannity
suggested correctly that at the time a
lot of people were saying that the virus
was under control including Bill
DeBlasio and Andrew Cuomo and more than
that the timeline just doesn't match up
they cited comments from from Sean
Hannity it does not match up with the
timeline like he went on the cruise
before Hannity said a lot of the things
he was quoted as saying so Sean wrote a
letter to the New York Times and said I
want a retraction and here was the New
York Times's reply in response to
requests for an apology and retraction
our answer is no that was the entire
reply and there and there look how brave
we are standing up to that evil Sean
Hannity well you got just slow clap guys
slow clap amazing amazing amazing and
meanwhile Andy lack who is one of the
editors he's the chairman of NBC News
and MSNBC he wrote a piece over at NBC
News called journalism is under his hat
from coronavirus and the White House but
we are winning we are winning Wow
he says President Trump came into office
railing against many of the foundations
of our democratic institutions including
a Free Press 40 months into his
administration
coverage of the corona virus outbreak is
the latest sign the contrary to
conventional wisdom he hasn't laid a
glove on serious journalism his attacks
most recently against excellent
reporters like Jonathan Karl you Misha
ålesund or Peter Alexander and Paula
Reid put the bully and bully pulpit but
they
and shaken the sole of the First
Amendment Wow Wow
don't don't stretch our arms oh don't
dislocate yourself patting yourself on
the back there Andy lack as faith in
media drops to record lows well done all
the way across the board you wonder why
people don't trust you there are plenty
of reasons why people don't trust the
media and they are all good reasons that
doesn't mean the media is always not
telling that the media is always lying
or that all information how the media is
bad it's not true but people have a
right to question your motives and your
methods of reporting when you act the
way you act with regard to everything
from from coverage of the White House to
coverage of Joe Biden already time for a
thing I like and then some things that I
hate so things that I like over the
weekend had the opportunity to watch my
parents we did a little bit of a movie
night a movie called the current war I
don't know what the original version
look like this is the director's cut the
director's cut is very good it's a good
movie it has about 60% on Rotten
Tomatoes the original has about 30% I'm
not sure why it's only at 60% the movie
is is compelling the performance is a
really good particularly Benedict
Cumberbatch as Thomas Edison Michael
Michael Shannon who's one of my Corky
favorites is plays the one of the other
electricity magnates West George
Westinghouse the move the movies really
good is really interesting and it's
about a period in time when industry was
in competition and sort of the dirty
tricks that were played by Edison Edison
was he was a ruthless ruthless dude and
he was very ruthless about going after
his competitors and trying to run them
out of business using the most
scurrilous strategies possible the movie
doesn't go easy on Edison but it also
paints a really well-rounded picture of
him here's a little bit of preview did I
mention that his systems lethal his
current kills people
he's playing dirty you can't - you can't
see the real force that moves things of
it's not a CDC it's of Torrance to
currency this is costing a Westinghouse
my mother that is our future you're
fired
they're never gonna be anything named
Tesla ever again our futures not okay
actually it's definitely worth the watch
it's it's an enjoyable interesting movie
I really don't understand why the why I
didn't get better reviews you go check
it out right now the current war it's
available on Amazon Prime you can you
can order it a little bit earlier okay
time for some things that I hate
if you think that Hollywood is not
biased all you have to do is take a look
at the fact that immediately after
leaving office the Obamas got a deal
from Netflix remember when the bush has
got a deal from Netflix I remember that
no no remember when they did a really
nice documents were about Laura Bush and
the troubles she had to suffer or about
george w bush and the situations he's
had to suffer to remember all of that
remember when they they just threw
contracts just real real contracts at
republicans leaving office i remember
that no i don't remember i know that
instead the Obamas leave office and
immediately they are ingested into the
Hollywood system cuz one thing you have
to know about Hollywood and I know
Hollywood fairly well I wrote a 400 page
book on it and I know tons of people at
the top levels of the industry not to
drop any names cuz I won't because then
they will be unemployed tomorrow if
people knew that they knew me
seriously I've met with like top members
of Hollywood people whose names you
would know I meet with them like off the
books at local restaurants back when
that was allowed wearing like sunglasses
and and hats because no one must ever
know that conservatives exist in
Hollywood this must remain a massive
secret well if you don't believe that
Netflix is about to drop a documentary
about the former First Lady Michelle
Obama
her and and it's produced by Barack and
Michelle Obama which is not vemos
self-aggrandizing thing ever it's maybe
like the second most self-aggrandizing
thing ever how did that pitch meeting go
exactly Christian Toto from from
Hollywood in Toto points this out how
did that pitch meeting go they're
sitting around at Obama productions and
they're like what should we produce next
in the interim those how about a
documentary about the Obamas everything
that's a great
idea we love those guys becoming which
is directed by Nadia halgren will take
viewers behind the scenes as Michelle
Obama traveled to 34 cities on the tour
for her book it will be released on may
6th this makes the second hagiography
about a Democratic mainstay in the last
three months he had Hillary Clinton they
did this celebrity or a documentary
about Hillary Clinton on Netflix then
you have the Taylor Swift documentary
which wasn't about a Democratic mainstay
but it turned her into a political
activist we mocked that bleep out of
that trailer because it was really a
very silly trailer miss Americana is
that what it was called and now they
have a a new one becoming it's the
latest film since the former president
and his wife signed the landmark deal
with the streaming service in 2018 the
pair who are on higher ground
productions were involved in camp
the Nicole noon hem and james labret
directed from about a summer camp for
teens with disabilities their first film
American Factory won the Best
Documentary Feature Oscar because of
course it had Obama's imprimatur on it
when I say that I know people in
Hollywood that was to say I sort of lost
my dream that was to say that in
Hollywood not only are they biased but
for Hollywood DC Democrats are
celebrities the way that it works in the
rest of the United States is if you're
in Hollywood you're a celebrity in
Hollywood these celebrities to people in
Hollywood are people like the Obamas
Obama was in fact the first celebrity
president I've said this before that
Barack Obama is basically the weird
bizarro world polar negative polarized
polarized photo of Donald Trump Donald
Trump was a celebrity who became
President Barack Obama was a president
who was a celebrity he was a celebrity
present wait when people say that we're
fundamentally unserious because Donald
Trump is president let me point out that
we elected a first term democratic
senator from Chicago who had never done
anything anything he made a speech at
the 2004 Democratic National Convention
he wrote a book that's it those are all
the accomplishments and we elected that
guy president because he was made of
celebrity and what regardless of what
you think about Barack Obama as
president the fact is he was a celebrity
president the man spent an enormous
amount of time hobnobbing with
celebrities far more than Donald Trump
does because celebrities would want to
be in his company a lot more because
he's palatable and worshiped so that
that is that is great news who becoming
is gonna be directed by nadya halgren a
filmmaker and cinematographer from the
bronx she's best known as the DP on
oscar-nominated and Sundance Grand Jury
Prize winning trouble the water and
CNN's when we rise Michelle Obama's
mission to educate
around the world Oh sis remember CNN
also did a hagiographic documentary
about Michelle Obama by the way the
remaking of Michelle Obama is one of the
most astonishing transformations in
modern American political history it
really is incredible in 2008 this was a
lady who's going around saying that this
is the first time she's been proud of
her country remember she was really
radical in 2008 like super radical she
was perceived as Hillary Clinton circa
1992 in 2008 now she's Oprah Winfrey and
that is really thanks to the hard work
of the people in Hollywood Michelle
Obama said those months I spent
traveling meeting and connecting with
people in cities across the globe drove
home the idea that what we share in
common is deep and real and can't be
messed with in groups large and small
young and old unique and United we came
together and shared stories filling
those spaces with our joys worries and
dreams we processed the past and
imagined a better future in talking
about the idea of becoming many of us
dared to say our hopes outloud I
treasure the memories and that sense of
connection now more than ever as we
struggle together to weather this
pandemic as we care for our loved ones
tend to our communities try to keep up
with work and school while coping with
huge amounts of lost confusion and
uncertainty and then she said that
people would find respite in the film
she did she says that the GP understands
that the director understands the
meaning of community power of community
her work is magically able to depict it
oh how beautiful how beautiful and of
course all of the all of these stills
from the film from the film are people
crying with Michelle Obama as she gives
them hugs now you know who is good at
giving hugs and was a nice lady at Laura
Bush and they never did any of this
stuff Laura Bush I remember when I was
at UCLA the Anderson Business School was
protested because Laura Bush was
supposed to speak at commencement
they've never made a documentary about
Laura Bush who by the way is a class act
and the only thing they've ever said
about Nancy Reagan is that she's a nasty
cuss the only thing that Holly will ever
make about a Republican woman is this
ridiculous series called Mrs America Mrs
America on what is it
FX this ridiculous series about Phyllis
Schlafly who's supposed to be just the
worst person in the world where you have
Kate Blanchet doing her brittle Cate
Blanchett routine because obviously the
greatest villainous in the world is a is
a woman who stood up against the
radicals who are pushing the Equal
Rights Amendment back in 1976 by the way
a story that America desperately needs
right now in 2020 is a biopic of Phyllis
Schlafly the clamor was enormous
people were just dying to see it at
least you can make the case
then a Michelle Obama documentary is
based on the success of her book write
becoming has been a massive bestseller
or at least you can say there's demand
for it was there tremendous demand in
Hollywood to greenlight a story about
Phyllis Schlafly in the Equal Rights
Amendment it's just Hollywood is
ridiculous right just as I said earlier
the media are not trusted by America
Hollywood is not trusted by America and
frankly I think there can be a lot of
people across the country who are not
particularly shedding a lot of Tears for
the people in Hollywood we're gonna be
losing a lot of money during this
pandemic as theater has closed down the
political bias in Hollywood is
ridiculous it is insane and it is and it
does radicalize the culture wars the
Republicans feel like you've lost the
high ground of culture and that means
that Republicans really feel relegated
to the realm of politics so if we're
gonna put all of our energies into
politics man then we are gonna punch
there then we're gonna punch there that
is that is the basic philosophy of a lot
of people on the right is why Trump is
so popular because he's a culture
warrior not really because he's a
politician because he does fight out
fight back against the perception but
the commanding heights of culture and
decency are carried by the same left
it'll greenlight any film that rips into
the right and praises the left alrighty
we'll be back here tomorrow with much
much more or two hours later day also
tonight 5 p.m. eastern front p.m.
Pacific 8 p.m. Eastern I'll be doing
Lara all-access I don't know how to
pinch that other than to say I'll be
wearing a t-shirt so go check that out
tonight become a subscriber over daily
we're calm when you go to daily we're
calm / subscribe to get two of these
beverage vessels you'll enjoy them so go
check that out you're listening to the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]